todos los acentos cadena y Madrid todos
los acentos caben en Madrid sí señor
todos los acentos caben en Madrid con
este lema se desarrollan las fiestas de
la hispanidad en la capital española
donde viven más de 210.000
latinoamericanos del 4 al 12 de octubre
la ciudad es el escenario para celebrar
la diversidad cultural de culturas que
conviven en ella uno de los platos
fuertes es esta cabalgata en la que
participan agrupaciones que al menos
cinco países latinoamericanos estamos
representando las danzas de la Patagonia
de chile que son los que están a mi
espalda y los que estamos llevando la
bandera como de la zona central la zona
guasa de chile somos el grupo leyendas
de México con base aquí en Madrid y es
una muestra de todos los trajes típicos
que tenemos en nuestro país que es muy
vasto y venimos acompañados de mariachi
por supuesto
una manera de centrarse en la unión de
los más de 600 millones de
hispanohablantes en el mundo y alejarse
del polémico inicio de esta festividad
Aunque la polémica en Paraguay está
servida en Paraguay tenemos una danza
muy llamativa que es la danza de las
botellas que lo hacen las mujeres en el
caso de ser algo folclórico no se puede
pero en calidad de show nosotros nos
vamos a presentar a él como como un
botellero en admiración a las mujeres de
su tierra él va a homenajear a sus
mujeres con la danza de las botellas
también nueve días de danza teatro
gastronomía conferencias y música entre
los conciertos más esperados el de
Camilo el cantante colombiano dará a
conocer su último disco de adentro para
afuera en la madrileña Puerta de Alcalá
este domingo
[Música]